all
[Music]
we are not in parliament a
court we are a
democratic body whose mission is to
protect and organize and therefore in
responsibility we said we are not going to bring
a prosecution  on monsanto
bayer syngenta synn china or on
water points no no by together to wet the
honey of the flights tomorrow on the question of
conflicts of interest we said we will
take the whole
approval procedure
you have a pest that will  attacking the
plant one of the major groups has carried out
investment work to find
a molecule to eliminate this pest
a protocol is being put in place to
authorize the marketing of this
molecule 1
because a priori it will be effective in
eliminating the visible but  also it
will have no impact on human health
or on
labrecque biodiversity there are words still not
there are words then action here
today on the world under the marquee
l  he living world, what goes from the
seed to the plate, in the end,
the world is governed by three large
multinationals who master this module, but
the world market a word on a text
of law can be worth millions or
even billions of euros.  can
understand that the first concerned
can be attentive to the content of our
work in recent months my mailbox
here in this office in the european parliament
has been diverted since all the e-
mails which contained the word
cancer did not reach the
central channel were unlinked  in a box that
contained glyphosate and she's
straight in the trash so there she
's the people and laughs because she has
she's a few months old six-fold page
it's not like bovine hoog wrote
see I contain  pesticide
here it was bigger offices so at
first I thought it was a joke so
dairy colleagues we
went around all the offices which a
priori it is  It's not a joke from my
colleagues from large dairy products like
and end to end these elements there we
obviously realize that there is an
insidious pressure that is being organized
[Music]
what is important to our proposals
is all d  first of all to answer the
question of the conflicts of interest of the
transparency of the harmonization in
the evaluation of the molecules and deco
formulating between the European level and the
national level to answer the
question of the quality
finally therefore of the research and  of
science and the harmonization of means
today we can clearly see the significance
of industry and agrochemicals in
what we ingest solid or
liquid and that therefore we are not
always guaranteed  how to say that the
guys we consume his example of
harmful materials
we will regain citizen trust
because we will give
guarantee protocols that those who are going to ingest
bullets will be products of excellent
quality
[Musiq  eu]